was a bunch of like German protesters
outside of your father's talk just like
Jordan Peterson
you're German
no what a fascist is like you would know
it intimately
[Music]
welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
Luke cook
thank you so much for having me Michaela
that was beautiful
I really appreciate that no of course
it's it's an incredible theme song and
it gets stuck in my head all the time so
I just had to give it to you but the
funniest video I've seen so far today
was a bunch of like German protesters
outside of your father's talk just like
Jordan Peterson
you're German you should surely know
what a fascist is like you would know it
intimately you know you've got this
wrong this one I know pretty weird huh
it's so weird how can you honestly call
yourself an anti-fascist and try and
de-platform people like try and not let
people speak how is that an where's the
intellectual honesty in that there isn't
any yeah people are very nice and your
mom your little mom posting a picture of
the I know the picket line I'm just
imagining her like and she just didn't
seem to care she's like look at these
people yeah yeah just like five foot
walking around here's the antique
outside my husband's show the antifa she
would call it the antifa and then she
posted on the Facebook yeah and the
Instagram she has a podcast Now isn't
that fun I'm yet to listen to her but I
I believe that did she do one with your
dad where she was talking with him yeah
about their relationship their marriage
and stuff like that that sounds
fascinating yeah it was pretty cute okay
before we get into all this can you give
a brief background about who you are and
what it is you do sure yeah um my name
is Luke cook I'm an actor
um you may know me from Guardians of
Galaxy 2 chilling Adventures of Sabrina
Dynasty doll phase and I've been acting
since I was a teenager and then in the
last few years I've kind of found myself
with this following on Instagram and
Tick Tock uh where I just make really
silly content and not until recently did
I start a podcast uh where I talk about
health and wellness uh but in a light
way and also not just health and
wellness I just I just had an only fans
guy on I've got an escort coming next
week so I kind of keep it sexy and
interesting and not just talking about
how good Omega-3s are for you all the
time that gets Bland it does get Bland I
kind of started my podcast in the health
Niche too mostly because that's what I
was interested in learning about so I
was like oh I can just sneak all these
experts in have conversations hey it's
for my podcast can I just pick your
brain for an hour sure like ha what a
scam yeah exactly but you see like it
only takes one podcast for somebody to
say how good meat is that you're just
and then you're finished I mean as far
as your diet is concerned it's like is
salt good good is me good good I think
we're done
yeah I had to move away from it there's
only so much you can say that's funny
yeah now you're in the space of excuse
me but you're in the space of doing like
having arguments uh getting people who
disagree with each other on your podcast
which I just think is it's amazing that
people can paint you as anything like
that people can paint you as this wild
crazy conservative when you have people
of multiple viewpoints on your podcast
I know it's ridiculous the real
conservative um my husband I was just I
was wearing a Edward Scissorhands I'm
still kind of pissed off I I entered
this podcast like angry because I
couldn't figure out how to turn a light
on and then I was wearing this Edward
Scissorhands shirt and it was really
cool it's my favorite shirt and he's
like that shirt looks bad I was like it
doesn't look bad it's really cool and
he's like it's ratty and you should wear
something cuter I was like that's what a
conservative person is like Nixon my
Edward Scissorhands shirt anyway I did
change it actually did look bad turned
out on camera but that's not the point
yeah well it turns out he's right too so
that's annoying so how did you get
started I want to get into your acting a
little bit uh and what that's like I've
always been interested in in acting I
don't think I could do it though you
know it's kind of like when you talk to
a singing teacher they'll say that
anyone can sing and I think I I think
you could look the fact that you can
speak publicly that's a huge uh you know
step to get over in order to be an actor
in the first place people say that
there's two things that freak everyone
out it's bugs and public speaking well
you're already good at public speaking
you can already do it you're not afraid
to do it I say like add a now add
learning lines to it and then that's the
next phase and then add character to it
and thinking about what is my part in
this story a lot of people get into
acting thinking that it's all going to
be a big show about them and some people
that that you you probably wouldn't like
that but the actually the idea of acting
is that I play a brick in the wall of a
whole story so you don't have to get up
and entertain or be amazing you just
have to play your part uh so you know so
so often we see parts in t TV which are
it's just a guy delivering pizza and
there's nothing about the scene all he
has to do is deliver the pizza if you
guys if you get a guy who's an
Entertainer on there he'll want to do
too much and it's like no just deliver
the pizza that's your job and you know
that's the job of most actors just
deliver the pizza just be the brick in
the wall you don't have to do much more
than that so I think that you may be
overstayed or you have oversaw what it
means to be an actor it's actually quite
simple it's just playing your part in a
story so you're about to have another
baby yes yes we're about to have a
second boy in November uh he'll be born
about the same time as my other son
who's turning two at the same time very
nervous
um and excited at the same time what are
you nervous about just the the challenge
of uh of a new thing that you've got to
keep alive you just don't know what um
you just don't know with with my wife
you can't tell how she's gonna be able
to handle it if she's going to have a
battle the first baby that we had she
had trouble feeding him mastitis and she
thought she was gonna die it was a real
struggle oh my God she had about five
different pros come in to try and teach
her how to do it and it was just a
battle and it was just a stressful time
so and then and then there's the change
of then there's that initial period and
then there's the change of all the time
you know the of how inconvenient having
a second one might be there's really
going to have to be all like one person
is going to have to man one of the
children and another person is gonna man
the other one and what that's going to
mean for my personal time of which you
know I value that time I really like
love to go and be by myself make stupid
content do what I need to do uh now
there's a second priority and
um yes it's all uh um it was it's all a
negotiation I find and I and I'm I'm
nervous about continuing to negotiate I
think that's probably wise yeah how do
you know do you did you struggle with
negotiating like time you you're a
person who's like working for yourself
and also like trying to make content and
stuff like this did you struggle to
negotiate that time alone to be with
your kid and and to go and work to
I wasn't alone for a the first year yeah
but you had to negotiate with him right
in order to be able to go and do your
thing oh um honestly I really wasn't
alone for about a year I just had
Scarlett kind of strapped to me and I
had a lot of chairs that she could sit
in she was just kind of attached to me
really uh which was I I don't think was
great for me I think that there are some
women that are really built to do child
care as their primary thing like my
sister-in-law she's really good at it
and I like I was a nanny for a number of
years
um as a teenager and in my young 20s and
I really enjoyed it but like I don't
think I'm agreeable enough to have like
a baby strapped to me constantly I go a
little bit nuts with like there's a
bunch of things I want to do how do I do
them like it's like a frustrating
position to be in and I'm sure lots of
people when they first have a baby get
for I wasn't frustrated with Scarlett
it's just frustrating to have something
that I mean I don't know if that's
narcissistic or what but that isn't you
to like take care of it wasn't her
either exactly that was frustrating it
was
I missed the productivity honestly it's
as simple as that but it was worth it
like you I I know now that when I have
another kid and I'm planning on having
more kids I need to
wrap my rap my mind around really taking
at least six months off just being like
okay the baby's here that six months
don't worry about work I had like work
guilt and things hanging over me it was
like don't worry about it you have like
a new life focus on that that'll pass
and then you can have some more
productive time I mean I navigated it
Scarlet's great I'm alive so everything
worked out it is deeply inconvenient
like we and that's how young people
mostly think about kids it is deeply
yeah yeah you just you can't imagine how
much you're going to love this little
thing though like Beyond exactly love
for any adult you've ever met in your
life you will have this love for this
thing so yes inconvenient but also deep
love the other thing I'll say is the the
difficulty of the negotiation especially
with between partners on taking care of
kids is well you assume that like so for
instance when Cara had our first child I
was like okay great well it looks like
you're going to take care of him and I'm
going to go and work and you you're
going to rest and you know recuperate
and take care of him and that's that's
going to be your thing but it turns out
no it's actually like no we're 50 50
splitting and you're going to go and
work
and so and that's and that's difficult
so and I it's really important to like
kind of be open
about
you know are you going to be are you
going are you going to really want to be
a mum and be a mum like a lot or are you
we wanting to split this of which point
a guy has to go it'd be great to get
some help maybe a family yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so being near family is
incredible so if you know my
mother-in-law for instance she's in
she's an amazing person and and very
very helpful my mom describes my
mother-in-law is having a servant's
heart which he very much does so like
one night she just gave all of us foot
um spas and she's just like that type of
person she's brought out the Foot Spa
and you know she's and she's a cleaner
by trade
um and to have her around was just a
godsend it is beyond what you could like
you know we're Beyond thankful to have
somebody like that so if you can have
family nearby highly guaranteed yeah
highly recommended sorry yeah yeah yeah
yeah I I agree I think that's what my
parents were on a tour when I had
Scarlett for you know that was like when
things got really quick crazy in 2017
2018 and my in-laws didn't like me so
that wasn't issue so so it was tough it
was tough but I I do agree that the
overwhelming love makes it worth it It's
Tricky society's also not optimized for
that at all like I know I've done some
research on how tribes used to operate
and you'd have women that had you'd have
different roles in tribes right so you'd
have the women that were really good at
taking care of kids taking care of kids
and then you'd have women off going to
get food and then you'd have people
hunting you'd have people building
things but it wasn't like like now
families are so isolated that it's like
well the woman in that family or the man
or however it's split up they'll be the
one staying at home and if you have two
hyper productive people then you're kind
of like missing a person but uh
regardless I would say
children are still worth it you just
have to figure out how to navigate that
right like figure out how to get help I
think is important especially if you can
afford help figure out how to get some
people there ideally I mean if you have
family around yeah family you just don't
have to pay for that's a good thing
about family but the other thing about
the tribes is it's which is amazing to
think about is they shared breastfeeding
duties so there will be like six women
doing the breastfeeding who could do it
at any one time can you imagine that
it's not much more sense yeah oh that's
can you imagine that's cool yeah like it
would they would have been like strong
as anything oh okay I didn't I didn't
think about that yeah from a health
perspective an immune system perspective
but also when you first have a kid like
they're attached to you they're nursing
like every two hours it's crazy and then
you don't sleep it's like good luck like
not especially if you're not inclined to
use formula and I was so paranoid about
formula
um I was like nah not doing any formula
um and it was like every two hours
which is not conducive to staying sane
yeah I mean I figured out that Cara who
was going through hell wasn't willing to
part with the hell I was like yeah let's
do a bit let's do a bit of formula she's
like no I no and I'm like you're in half
you're in hell and she just doesn't want
to leave and so I found out that I
discovered that about my partner during
that time was like oh my gosh like you
actually like if I offer you a way out
of hell you don't necessarily take it I
don't know if it's martyrdom or if it's
like I don't know what it is but
eventually I think I was like that
right yeah when she was first born I was
like yeah no no no I wasn't sleeping and
things and I was like no she's not
leaving me it was like you're going
crazy
it's like I know I can't I can't live
like this but like
we'll just see what happens I guess
this episode is sponsored by nordvpn
nord's virtual private Network hides
your data from authoritarian governments
or even non-authoritarian governments
and protects your data from any unwanted
third-party overreach are there really
non-authoritarian governments though or
is the entire thing a scam I used to
think Canada had a good stable
government now I do not that's all I'll
say here for now nordvpn encrypts data
by using an encrypted tunnel that
conceals your activity online without
risking the Integrity of your personal
information or your privacy vpns like
the one Nord offers are particularly
beneficial if you're in a situation
where your government completely limits
or shuts down access to the internet
which can happen with absolutely insane
governments Iran currently China it's
crazy nordvpn keeps your location
private and your internet access secure
so that people can't discover where you
live or where you're working from
wherever you are protect yourself and
the free flow of information by grabbing
your nordvpn deal today over at
nordvpn.com
tmpp or use the promo code tmpp for a
whopping 61 off their Premium plan and
their free anti-malware feature all with
nordvpn's 30-day money-back guarantee
yeah and there is a way in which you can
mimic or at least try to mimic breast
milk nothing really does but if you are
if you're out there and you're listening
to this and you're like oh how do I do
it there is a way you know you get it
the best you know formula that you can
afford there's a really good company
called Serenity kids they do an age oh I
love that formula yeah they're amazing
and you mix it with uh cod liver oil so
vitamin D and DHA and then a kids
probiotic
um with the bacto all that one
um and so it's coming close to breast
milk but still not it's nothing's going
to be as good but there is a way in
which you can you know if you're going
through hell you know maybe go okay 50
50. I'll do 50 the formula does the
other 50. give yourself a break
yeah stay sane not a special
relationship too because it's it's hard
it can be tough at the beginning yeah
especially if you're both kind of going
crazy yeah okay so that's interesting
the serenity kids I like Serenity kids
like their their food that is good kid
food that's good adult food like that's
just good food Serenity kids and you
said you mix cod liver oil in and we'll
maybe drink that they do babies like you
know as far as they're concerned they
don't know what horrendous fish taste
like they'll do it they'll do you know
they'll do they'll do liver like you
know one of Chaplin's first foods was
liver and we were watching him like hold
this long slip like it was um this long
string of liver because they can't choke
on it because it's too big so he's just
kind of annoying on it and we're like
that I we would I would never eat liver
straight like that but you can't you
can't yuck their yum if they like it
it's just like good it's so nutritious
and great for them but yeah cod liver
oil is one of those things super high in
DHA and vitamin D cool okay yeah well
that's that's helpful information
um I started following you a long time
ago and your Instagram's very
entertaining and your Tick Tock is quite
entertaining too so I would recommend
that it's good it's good Instagram
content rather than just following
political people all the time yes yes I
had a woman the other day she didn't
follow me but she was like I posted this
mockery of Adam Levine
um and and she was like uh Luke cook who
are you going to vote for in the
midterms and why and I was like well
firstly I'm not an American
uh and secondly like not everything has
to be about that she's like you're
posting trash gossip let's talk about
something with substance and I'm like
you know a lot of people don't
um don't see Politics as straight
substance there's a lot of trash in
politics and a lot of people are tired
of it and I think they'd rather talk
about gossip and like you know nothing
things than talk about politics who you
know let's not assume that politics is
so interesting is so interesting to
people are so vital or so substantial I
think people have fed up with it it's
also full of gossip as well it's kind of
the same thing absolutely and you know
and these people who are like
politicians and they're as immoral as
anything and we're following along like
they have something of substance to give
and they're all stringing us along too
sorry I'm getting a little bit like
ranty but I'm not I don't think that I
don't think that talking about politics
is necessarily like you know nutritious
conversation or conversation to stay
sane that's why I'm trying to keep it
live on Instagram that was the point of
that ran I I want to keep things light
and fun so that you know you have a
break from all of the news I think
that's good maybe if everyone just took
a break people would be saying her quit
following anyone who discusses anything
political I went through Instagram the
other day and unfollowed a bunch of
people I was like it's too Str it's not
I don't get stressed really from it but
like it's not I get worked up for sure
like they did what this stupidity is
going on which is like you should be
aware but I don't know how much of that
actually just plays into increasing the
amount of stupidity that's around yes
I'm not sure actually that how much
awareness actually helps anything like
my awareness of the situation in
um South Korea North Korea I'm not sure
that I could actually do anything about
that I I think that if I can be good to
my neighbors my family and my friends
strangers on the street if I can be good
and loving to them then surely that does
more good for the general populace than
me worrying about the Ukraine you know
and me being aware of the I don't know
what my awareness can possibly do it it
might tell me who to vote for uh like
really like that's really like the
height of awareness like I don't know I
I don't know if awareness actually does
does that much I think that you can do
much more within your inner circle right
now than you can do about being aware of
what's going on on the other side of the
world I like that I think I probably
have a mixed opinion on that I feel like
some people being aware about things can
help but for the majority of people
maybe being less aware and focusing on
people nearby and being a good person is
what helps yeah rather than trying to
something by the way yeah yeah yeah my
dad seems to be able to care about a lot
of different situations and connect them
right and well I guess he can kind of
understand them all too you know for me
it's just a big mess I don't know what
NATO is and I don't know what's going on
in Russia and Ukraine I really don't
understand it whereas he it might
understand the history of everything
like that which will kind of make it an
intellectual Pursuit which would be
enjoyable but not not it's just not for
me no fair enough fair enough okay so
let's get into acting a little bit you
said you been acting since you were a
kid when did did you want to do that
were you forced into it how old were you
when it started oh no I wasn't a child
star by any means I was I just liked
going and doing the plays in school
um and I just found that I was
happiest there there was no I I do often
think about the expectations of my peers
about them going oh Cook's gonna do the
play he'll do the play
um and if I met tried to meet those
expectations or if it's really what I
wanted but I would just I did find that
I just had this entertainment bone I
don't really if I was to re if I was to
say what I do I would say I'm more of an
Entertainer than an actor because I just
like trying to try to make people laugh
rather than like pure actors like Colin
Firth for instance like that guy doesn't
have Instagram he's not interested in it
at all he doesn't he doesn't do you know
um campaigns to make people love him he
just wants to show up sit up on set and
act whereas I want a little bit more
than that I'd like to like be able to
make you laugh
every second day if I can why why do you
care about that uh it's not that I care
it's just that if
I see that um
for a lot of people I you wouldn't
believe the amount of messages I get of
people who write to me and say I was
having the worst day and I just came to
your page and you did this video and it
just I did a 180 on where I was and you
just go okay well that's worth something
that's uh like if I can turn your day
around with a laugh that's actually like
worth something to people I mean and
that this is and also Michaela this is
me convincing myself that what I do is
worthwhile too like I I have to make
sure that like I want to keep doing it
you know and say that and not think of
myself as this idiot clown all the time
like there's there's I do but I do
honestly think that some good comes of
my silliness
um so
yeah that's why I I keep going at the
same time I do need breaks like I need a
break probably around now I've been
going too hard for too long and the
Brain needs to stop thinking of the
world as content and start thinking of
the world as the world hmm I like that
okay so do you think adding in your
podcast to all the social media is just
it's a lot of content right now it's a
lot of content and it's so just yeah
it's I like the podcast because it gives
people another another look inside of
who I am rather than just the silliness
or just the big acting roles it also
gives them like get an access to me and
and what I find interesting but it is it
is crazy like I I am a sensitive human
being so if I put information out into
the world from somebody who knows what
they're talking about people get angry
at that yesterday I did a video about 5G
and I had a doctor on there talking
about the effects of emfs and 5G and 5G
plus oh no which is you know I have you
know she's so avoided that
she talked about how it's an experiment
on an experiment anyway I posted it and
she like what it does to the cells it
makes like calcium leak from the cell
essentially of your in your body and
people were just so angry and and people
were like this is misinformation you
have a huge platform you should get
somebody on here who disagrees with it
with peer-reviewed studies blah blah
Calling Me Irresponsible saying that she
wasn't a real doctor
um and I was like okay well like
um I really I really hate this because
it's not a hill I want to die because
it's not that I it's not that I agree or
disagree with her it's just that I'm
putting information out into the world
and people are saying you can't put that
information out into the world and I'm
just too sensitive for it so I'm trying
to I love being controversial but I
don't I don't like it in that way I
don't like when people are yelling at me
I I can't quite take that I think you
get used to it I like I really do think
you get used to it yeah you get used to
it it's much more stressful at the
beginning and then later it's like yeah
they'll just unfollow you and go follow
somebody else yeah and I do wonder I
have yeah I have to one and ask myself
the question am I being a [ __ ]
or or am I am I sensitive and that's the
thing to say that you go okay well I
don't want to feel this way or am I
supposed to go into the unknown a little
bit go like okay you don't like it and
you can't take you know people asking
questions and talking about certain
issues then effia I'm going to keep
going though so I I fight with that idea
in my brain I think it's that I think
then you get less sensitive to it too I
like I really do think it's that because
also people if someone's following you
and they're like oh I don't like this
one person you talk to and they can't
understand that you're a human being
who's inviting other human beings onto a
podcast that and you guys both have
flaws and it's just information if that
person can't understand that then who
cares what that person thinks
you're right but you did just call me a
[ __ ]
at the beginning of the journey though
maybe it's stressful it's stressful when
people disagree with you especially if
you're talking about things like 5G and
those are just people who really like
their
their cell phones and their airpods and
things this is why I've avoided this
people are like you're frying your brain
and I'm like you know what
probably
I know I know look and here's the thing
that I don't necessarily think that it's
as bad as certain people might say it is
or as
fine as people say it is all I know is
that I don't I wouldn't put my son's cot
next to the Wi-Fi router would you put
your baby's cot next to the Wi-Fi router
and no one is going to say yes to that
and you go why and you go well just
because you don't know I was well then
well then we should be able to talk
about it would you put your son's cot
next to the microwave
absolutely hell no oh okay well then
let's take it a step down let's go to
Wi-Fi it's got a 5G let's ask those
questions I just think I could say but I
you know but we should be able to talk
about it you know it's like the it's
like the big V we weren't allowed to
talk about that a lot of women were
saying that it helped like they they got
their period straight after the vaccine
they were talked down to they were
scolded they would gaslighted I hate
using that word because it's so popular
now but it's true they were gaslighted
and then you were gonna end up finding
out that they were correct that they
weren't lying at all and that a huge
percentage of the population the female
population had late periods because of
the vaccine so it's like the question
that you couldn't ask only 10 months ago
is now factual
yeah that's why you also can't
cower not saying you're cowering either
but that's why you also can't take the
masses seriously too if you have an
inkling about something like you can be
wrong a lot of the time but you might be
talking about something that's true so
if you're like well maybe I'll shy away
from that and then 10 months later it's
like oh no that was spot on and I knew
it I'd say like people who actually
follow you too and who are sane are
forgiving if you run across someone
who's like not forgiving then just
ignore them I appreciate that that's
good advice plus it gets easier the more
it happens it wouldn't win and it really
does the like controversy my dad went
through every time when he first
like became more well known every time
there was a negative article you know
like New York Times there was one that
was pretty and I think they made more of
an impact too before I think they come
out now and people like eh no one trusts
mainstream media anyway but in 2018 it
was a bit of a different story and every
time it was like the end of the world it
was so stressful it's the end of the
world it was what our friends gonna
think how is this going to impact my job
it was like crazy and it'd be this like
week and a half of just utter panic
and then things would just continue
and things would get better
like it wasn't even negative it looked
negative but it turned out to be
positive later and so now it's just like
it's kind of a joke I don't know if
that's how mainstream media is or if you
just you really just get used to it yeah
I'd love to know about like how how we
can remain resilient to like stay on our
message
despite that the ample hate that can
come in as a result of what you do you
know even having a discussion with
somebody on a podcast or telling young
men that they're worth worthy of
existence
you know spreading that message and it
cops you a barrage of hate and then
you're just like wow you know maybe I'm
on the right path then actually yeah
yeah that and also you have to look at
how much support you're getting because
you know you focus on the hate it's way
easier to focus on the hate you you have
to just listen to The Voice in your head
I think at some point like well really
think about it are you doing anything
wrong and if there's nothing in you
that's like well did you lie about
something like are you you know living a
lie like that conversation were you just
curious about it you're just talking to
someone about it there's nothing wrong
with that so then you can ignore
everybody else
if you're right [ __ ] him yeah yeah I
like that I don't know how how well that
attitude Works in Hollywood though yeah
I mean I yeah I'm not sure about
Hollywood anyway I I really can't
continue to try and figure out in my
head what Hollywood is what Hollywood
wants what they don't want I I I I can't
because
um if I keep thinking about it I'll just
go insane I have to just be myself I I I
can't find any other way around it I've
been trying and thinking about what do
they want what do they want do you want
this and it's like if you want to do a
dance in your underpants Luke to Taylor
Dayne go go for it [ __ ] them they'll
figure it out is is it you is it your
truth is this really what you want to do
then go for it effem they'll figure it
out if they don't want you fine are you
going to be not yourself and pretend to
be this Henry Cavill serious English man
for the rest of your life you know I
don't even have sex you know it's like
uh like I don't want to be a I don't I
just I'm not Bland I'm just not so I
refuse to pretend to be Bland in order
to fit in with you know the Hollywood
leading men who are just like you know
like have you ever done anal like have
they ever done anal have they ever tried
something new have they ever done a bump
of coke like what do we what do we know
about these people like who are we look
up to this is why they avoid this is why
they avoid Instagram
Henry County Bland
that's funny but he's he's so handsome
though I mean what are you gonna do he's
so handsome doesn't matter
he's very handsome I when I was like 23
I remember for some reason I don't even
know I got on this I was on a lot of
Adderall and that is that's a dangerous
thing to do and I needed to be on it for
chronic fatigue in order to stay awake
but like that doesn't mean that I didn't
have Adderall side effects and I got it
into my head I was living with my one of
my dad's grad students and we just
decided to find the most attractive
people on the internet just to see you
know and I don't know it's like I think
I got into I was like do is what women
find attractive the same thing as what
men find attractive so I was like this
is what I think the most attractive men
it looks like what do you think the most
attractive man looks like and this is
like a psychology PhD student so we were
having this conversation for a while I
think it was mostly Adderall induced
anyway long story short Henry Cavill
that's what I determined was like the
most attractive man out there
when I was incredibly attractive and
it's and he's so attractive it
necessitates like he doesn't even have
to have a a personality he's that good
looking
you know so for every point of
attractiveness under eye under Henry
Cavill I am I kind of have a a notch of
Personality that he didn't get you know
what I mean I feel like that's a good
trade-off though it's a good trade-off
I'll take character any day it'd be nice
to know what it's like to be a 10 though
it would be nice to know what that's
like like a full tan like in like
undeniably like 10 as you walk down the
street it'd be nice to know what that
feels like it probably feels fantastic
like I feel like anyone saying it
doesn't feel fantastic is just lying
it's like oh no look at me too much yeah
exactly oh okay no that is a thing sorry
I will say that is a thing and I I've
known like some incredibly beautiful
women
um and they you know you think about uh
for a beautiful woman who just they make
men so self-conscious so that they never
actually get to hang out with a a guy
who is just relaxed and who can be
himself because the guy's always putting
it on an ass because he's around this
like incredibly attractive woman I do
feel sorry for very very very attractive
women I think it's really really hard
because they never get
is that is that dependent on the man
they're around though or do you get to
the level where it's just all men I
think they I think they would love to be
in the in the presence of gay men
because gay men on it wouldn't be
attracted to them so that they can be so
they can feel like a male a male
relationship that is relaxed there you
just can't fathom how uncomfortable men
get around very very attractive women
they stutter on their words even if
they're very confident they put it on an
ears they act like they're better than
they are and they don't even not realize
that they're doing it and the and so
these women are like wait is this what
men are like it's it's awful like it's
not enjoy it's not it makes me feel
uncomfortable because if you were
hanging out and you're uncomfortable
I'll probably feel it yeah too so it's
like all these women ever get to know is
uncomfortable men self-conscious men you
know I reckon it'll be really hard like
as you actually never get a view into
a nice relaxed man I know like you're
trying to work on my pity for women that
are a 10 but I'm just I'm not I'm trying
I'm trying I don't feel it though like
anywhere like I I like I get that but
okay mate like maybe a little like 10
pity there maybe
I don't know it's just stretch
you know you you can hang out Michaela
and you're still very attractive but you
can be one of the boys and the boys can
relax and it's all good like Victoria's
Secret models as in not the new ones the
old ones they sit down at a road at a
table full of men men cannot handle
themselves they just like they can't
even look them in the eye so think about
a woman who's a 10 who's she's like why
can't this guy look me in the eye like
why kind of advice is not one can make
eye contact with me it's because the man
is like it
you know sputtering like idiots like
that's all that they get to know
okay I can understand you don't know no
no I I don't not really
um no I don't I don't I can see why one
would but I don't does everybody in
Hollywood have a nose job
um
um
not nose job but everybody in Hollywood
has work done so that the people that
you have in your mind has been the most
attractive that you would like to look
like have all had ample work done over
the years have you seen Angelina Jolie
recently looks exactly the same as she
did 20 years ago she looks great
she's incredible I mean you know she's
always been number one for yeah I mean
she's always been like oh my God she's
still going yeah
my wife too is incredibly attractive but
I'm talking yes like the people we're
pinning up on our walls going I want to
look like that they've all had work done
not one of them hasn't because they can
be so subtle now with all the things
that they can do to you including to the
nose that like you they look exactly
like they did 10 years ago but
yeah we all think that they're doing
they're eating things that are really
good for them and so that's why they
look that way no they're not eating
collagen for breakfast lunch and dinner
they're getting work done ample so it's
not just College collagen and olive oil
no collagen olive oil and yogurt amen
but if I was to choose if I was to
choose a diet just for beauty it would
be collagen yogurt and green juice green
juice
yeah like a cold pressed green juice
uh without the no kale no spinach no
collard greens the low oxalate greens
and and but by the way your skin will
still sag because they haven't found
that collagen actually links to your
skin yet and has any effect
aesthetically on your skin what what I
didn't know that
oh that Mark is a lie
I have a lie it's it's probably good for
you it's definitely good for you to have
more collagen collagen goes down as you
age helps with the elastin in your skin
but we there's no there's been no
science that proves that it
aesthetically helps your skin or your
face it's still great for you super high
in Glycine and great for the gut but um
yeah no we don't know that it does
anything for the skin the nails or the
hair yet I actually didn't know that
yeah that is kind of sad so you can't
you can't drink collagen and have
stronger nails they actually haven't
found an association no I don't think so
but you know you you eat a lot of meat
okay so you've heard of this thing
called methionine toxicity one of the
things that helps with methionine
toxicity when you eat too much animal
Foods is glycine which is in bone broth
and super high in bone broth so if
you're eating nose to tail or if you're
eating a whole bunch of meat it's good
to have some a bunch of glycine too like
bone broth can balance out the
methionine I'm so do you drink bone
broth can you drink bone broth
yeah but I don't I really basically just
eat
like red meat and steak and burgers and
burgers
yeah but just the burger like patties
right yeah I was gonna say you can't
just yeah it's just like the same but
ground version yeah no so not Burgers
yeah yeah it's good it's some variety
brisket and then ground brisket you know
yeah it is but um no I like when I eat
soup I was eating I was trying to eat
bone broth at the beginning of the diet
because I don't know you hear about what
you need and everything and it's like
well maybe bone broth is healthy and it
upset my stomach I've got histamine
intolerance like crazy so anything age
oh got it bone broth is just it isn't I
my stomach can't handle it so I eat soup
but it's like meat I just pressure cook
meat and then that turns into soup which
is also great
I wonder if you could pressure cook
bones it does take too long though
doesn't it so the history up over the
hours if they're not aged probably I
know bones generally aren't as aged but
the last time I pressure cooked bones my
stomach didn't like it and so no I
really just eat meat and meat soup and
different forms of of meat I don't even
eat organs
and I've been doing it since 2017. yeah
yeah you can't have liver you can't have
no I do I just don't I don't like it she
actually likes anyone like it it's
disgusting yeah no I'm not eating that I
I think I've eaten it basically once a
year since 2017.
um and then I don't think I've had it in
the last two years yeah and so how do
you do you take a pill form or have you
had the chips yet the carnivore really
is those are also like disgusting people
advertise those they're lying I know
this is the best form of liver it's not
very much better than normal liver but
it's crunchy like it's crunchy exactly
it's the texture because the texture of
liver is also gross on top of the taste
but I can take the taste I just can't
take the texture that's why I eat the
chips ah no I don't eat liver I don't
eat liver chips
fair enough and then I'm not gonna [ __ ]
I'm not gonna force you to okay okay
good so your podcast why why do you have
such a focus on health like my focus on
health is was brought on because
it was like a struggle I was dying and I
I hated people who focused on health
with like a passion like the gluten-free
people I hated them the people eating
organic I hated them too there was no
Rhyme or Reason why I hated the healthy
people
it didn't even I don't even think it was
Associated I was just like it's
narcissistic and annoying and it's in
your face and I don't want to hear about
your weird hippie stores and all of it's
false anyway and then I ended up on this
stupid diet that cured me and now I'm
like okay fine maybe some people out
there had a point about Alternative
Health but why did you get into it yeah
I can't say that like I didn't come from
it where I was like struggling with my
health at all I actually got into health
and wellness because of I was Vain and I
was like I want to make sure that I age
as well as I possibly can and then
um over the years it's the vanity is
Fallen away somewhat found it he's still
there but um I'm more I'm just and then
I became interested and became kind of
good at you know when you're when you
love when you love what you're listening
to you can take in the information very
easily and I just loved health and
wellness and so
um I kind of fell into it thanks to Dave
asprey I had an ex-girlfriend who used
to make um coffee with butter and she'd
blend it and I was like what is the this
why am I drinking butter and she told me
about this Dave asprey guy and uh anyway
when she stopped making those for me I
realized that we needed to break up
uh and because she just stopped doing it
one day and she was and I was like oh so
you don't really care anymore that's how
I knew that I needed to leave but so
Dave asprey was kind of my way in he was
the one talking about how fat isn't bad
for you red meat isn't bad for you put
butter in your coffee it's really
delicious and it is you know not
everyone should do it and it's not
something that I do all the time anymore
and then I I was like okay well that
this is really fun information and
everyone's talking about plant-based and
I'm like and I'm over here thinking
about how great red meat is for
everybody it's like okay well and then I
found myself in a community I loved Dave
asprey I loved Ben Greenfield I'm
fascinated by them I love biohacking I
love you know getting outside in the
nude getting under red light getting my
balls on red light uh does that okay is
that real does that work my husband's
really into that and I'm just like this
is so it's so obnoxious
it's so obnoxed like you know like last
night he's doing it and he like the
light shines up it's just like Wham
right in my eyes and I was just like
Jordan you need really this doesn't I
don't even believe this but is there
really there have been scientific
studies on like red light on your balls
increasing testosterone that's actually
peer-reviewed I'm not sure about that no
I wouldn't know if it's peer-reviewed or
anything like that I I do know that you
can overdo it though so you wouldn't be
wanting to do more you can overdo it you
can you can burn your swimmers if you
leave them under a red light for too
long so I would be staying I wouldn't be
doing it I used to do it for 20 minutes
a day when I when I first got into it
and that was unnecessary I was like a
virile 30 year old
um and I need you know I was like you
don't really need the help so I reckon
just doing it 10 minutes every so often
you don't have to be a crazy person
about it it you know red light is
probably great for you
um I I again I don't know what these
peer-reviewed things are saying but oh
you know on that bio-hacking thing I
also get into like 40 degree water every
morning for three minutes cool
do you have a cold Plunge at your place
I got a cold plunge yeah which is a
pretty terrific thing I mean mentally
what a win to get in get in and out of
cold water for three minutes first thing
that you do every day and you can get
out and it's like coffee before coffee
and the studies don't matter like the
excellent like what they found about
what has the effects on the brain and
that's cool what company do you use
they're the it's the it's called the
cold plunge and it looks like a what
it's a beautiful white bathtub
essentially oh I have a friend who has
one of those so you like that company I
love it love it yeah I mean there's the
there's other companies that like where
you're basically sitting on ice and
they'll go slightly below 40. this one
goes to 40. you don't need to really go
below 40 it's as cold as you can believe
and
um I love it and it looks and that's
just a good looking bathtub but
um and I do it every day it's something
that you can consistently do one and you
can teach yourself to even get better at
I'm not interested in getting better at
it I'm just interested in getting the
benefits brain wise
and um I love it okay I want to do that
that one it doesn't you don't have
actual ice chunks in there then do you
it's just cold cold it's just okay with
the benefits benefits are the same
benefits are the same I mean I can't
imagine that there'd be any benefits to
like there being a whole bunch of ice in
there
um looks better but I social media
content it does look better for social
media that you know you're getting in
and shivering and that that'll be enough
and saying that it's you know and that
you have a thing there that says it's 40
degrees and so everyone can know that
you're actually getting into 40 degree
thing it's it's it's Sensational and so
good for you and what they're just what
they're saying about like norepinephrine
and epinephrine in the brain like you
can go up by 300 in some cases just by
doing it about 14 minutes a week so
that's not a lot and pretty terrific for
the brain interesting okay I'm gonna do
that I got a sauna I've wanted a sauna
I've wanted a sauna for years yeah and I
have one now and it's amazing but what
did you get the infrared or did you get
the I have an infrared are you finding
it's helping with your condition is it
helping with inflammation I don't really
have very many symptoms anymore but it
helps if I get worked up about something
like if I'm stressed out
it helps and if I accidentally eat
something that gives me a reaction it
helps
it makes me feel good like it makes me
feel good I really like infrared saunas
and I liked it better than the than the
I guess the ones that aren't infrared
that just heat you up because I can stay
in there for a lot longer and just sweat
whereas the other ones I'd heat up and
I'd get hot and I'm already in Florida
it was like yeah I'd rather like get in
somewhere and really sweat than heat up
as much so I have a sauna and it doesn't
even have heaters at the front they're
ones that have yeah infrared and then
they'll have heaters at the front and I
got the type that doesn't even have
heaters at the front so it's just
sweating I don't get too hot it's nice
it's lovely
I think sauna is the next Frontier for
me like that'll be the next thing that I
get into I I am I have an issue with
heat I if I'm over if I overheat I get
angry if you want to piss me off give me
a cup of coffee put me in jeans and send
me out in the middle of the day and
that'll do it I'll be in absolute like
irritated like angry man and so maybe
learning resilience to build heat
resilience would be good for me hmm
that's interesting well the type the
type I have doesn't have heaters in it I
don't like the ones that have heaters
because getting hot like that makes me
uncomfortable and like weird irritated
yeah although I've gotten a lot much
better since I've been on the carnivore
diet I used to be hot all the time and I
was on a lot of medication too so it was
probably side effects but I was like in
tank tops and shorts in the winter hot
all the time and I'm not oh and now I'm
cold instead
it's better though like really cold
actually but it's better yeah I mean I'm
cold all the time now my body I don't
know what it is but ever since doing the
cold plunge I'm the one who turns off
the air conditioner now and my wife is
the one switching it back on and it I I
I'm wearing a sweater in the morning of
us in summer like walking around my
house and I used to look at people doing
that and go what do you do how it's
summer how are you doing that that's me
now it's very interesting and it has to
be the cold or and it could be Placebo I
don't know but I feel generally colder
all the time now
hmm that's cool
okay so that doesn't sound as good for
me but that could be good for that could
be good for my husband well you should
be going you can do the going between
thing we go and sauna jump into the cold
plunge back into the sauna and that's
been to be fantastic for you and Dr
Peter Adia has talked about how much his
deep sleep is improved by doing that at
night before bed his deep sleep is
improved by like an hour really by an
hour
yeah and that is an insane number for
anybody listening like it usually just
stick to about two hours for a lot of
people they just stick to a certain
number to refer to increase an hour is
that's a big difference
I was drinking um electrolytes for quite
a while like the flavored electrolytes
uh and they've got a they've got a good
dose of citric acid in them and it took
me about a year to figure out I was
reacting to the citric acid my deep
sleep I was getting 6 to 15 minutes of
deep sleep at night for a year and a
half yeah and it was when my dad was
really ill too and so
they overlapped so I was unbelievably
stress intolerant because I wasn't
getting any deep sleep and I was looking
at it was my aura ring was just like
driving me crazy it was like six minutes
it was like exhausted all the time I
wasn't sleeping and it turned out it was
a citric acid in the electrolytes so I
cut that out and then my deep sleep in
like in the next two weeks went back to
an hour which still isn't
it's not great
maybe I'll try that out well but I
imagine well and then also your ordering
can be wrong but uh you know the other
thing that you should you're you're so
you're Carnival which means very low
carbohydrate which means you need more
salt so how much salt do you and how
much electrolytes are you drinking every
day
I eat a lot of salt
I got a lot okay
I'd add more electrolysis
the unflavored type so it's just like
sodium potassium a little bit of
magnesium uh and I don't add too much
maybe one a day so that's an extra gram
of salt a day
um that's that's about it but I eat a
lot of salt in my meat good and then
your electrolytes uh you you have a new
electrolyte company and it has it's
salty one right that's the one yeah I
like the salty ones super salty it's
gonna have a gram of sodium and 300
milligrams of potassium and some
magnesium it's pretty much like you can
just make it I used to mix my own but
they're very salty and where did the
salt come from if you don't mind me
asking oh my gosh well it's not like
Redmond Real Salt I still use it it's
sodium chloride I don't know as soon as
this episode finished I had to find out
where the salt from my electrolytes is
sourced from because I've literally
spent two years trying to make these the
cleanest electrolytes out there the salt
is mined in Canada no flow agents are
used it's non-iradiated and totally free
of anything other than Salt from a mine
so we're good thought I'd pop in and
explain that real quick enjoy the rest
of this episode I don't know why people
don't appreciate the like the sweet
slash salty thing I [ __ ] love it oh
my gosh I tried to give it to some of
people who work for me because it turns
out because I've run on the carnivore
diet for so long when I was testing out
the cherry flavor I have a cherry flavor
that's going to be coming out and a
salted caramel which is going to be good
in tea
um but anyway I was testing them out and
I was like this these are repulsively
sweet
like this like this is so sweet like
this is way too sweet for me and and I I
gave one to a babysitter I was like what
do you think about this she goes you
know it's kind of like tonic water and I
was like oh no tonic water doesn't it
taste like Cherry this was the last
iteration so we switched things up um
but it turns out my taste buds are so
sensitive to sweet that I was like
undervaluing how sweet it it was I was
overvaluing it
yeah eat eat carbs it wasn't sweet to
them at all I was like uh got it what
about the this how is it sweet is it is
it sweet is it Steve you're in it or
something okay good yeah I like Stevia
and then
um the I reckon the The Salted one
salted caramel one that'll be great in
coffee because you don't you know like
Dave asprey's just come out with danger
coffee which is coffee slash minerals
like in in the beans there's minerals in
the beans that's cool and and so if you
were to like you know because I put salt
in my coffee every morning too salt and
cinnamon
um because you know coffee obviously
saps electrolytes and it's absalt from
your body and it makes sense like you
could put it in a salted caramel coffee
that's delicious I know it sounds good
okay I'll send it to you you can tell me
what you think I don't drink you drink
coffee no I don't drink anything I'm
probably not even going to use the
flavored electrolytes like they don't
have any citric acid in them so for
people who get stimulated from citric
acid they won't have that issue but
um I am still so crazily sensitive to
everything that I don't think I can like
I don't think I'll be doing that daily
anyway it'll it'll over stimulate me I
can't even take zinc I can't take zinc
because oh I don't know why I would take
zinc because I only eat meat I don't
really need to take zinc but I got I
kept getting sick Scarlett kept bringing
home horrifying child sicknesses and I
was just kidding child sickness after
child sickness and I was like maybe I
need some zinc and things and then I
couldn't sleep from the sink I was like
okay I guess I don't know what about
vitamin C needs is a carnivore how do
you get that can you can you take
Vitamin C or no
um so I don't uh I don't take any
vitamin and I had a bunch of vitamin
deficiencies before the carnivore diet
uh all my VB vitamins were low vitamin D
was low I have to get that rechecked I'm
in Florida now so I'm hoping that's been
bumped up but everything zinc was also
low everything fixed itself and vitamin
C has been been normal for me I don't
supplement but when kovid was going
around a bunch near the beginning I was
taking a little bit of vitamin and see
in a like powder form every day it also
tastes really good if all you eat is
meat it's got this like sour tart taste
that's like it's almost sweet and so
yeah ah yeah some vitamin C in my
sparkling water sweet
it's a minimalist yeah you said Luke
yeah easily pleased like by vitamin C
which is like yeah you might not enjoy
the taste oh it's so funny my dad at
restaurants he's on the same diet and
it's like the same thing he's got
allergies to everything as well and
he'll be like yeah I'll get some can I
have a sparkling water in a hot water
just get the like the two different
Waters going on so you you get creative
you get creative with variety
hahaha I mean I imagine that you're into
your souls too like it's not just one
type oh I've got to send you oh yeah
Lima salt
what is that it's it's it's it's it's
this new salt from Mexico it's flakier
than Malden no it's so CR it's so flaky
and so crunchy it's amazing and akara we
were obsessed with Melvin before and we
could run everything and now we're
putting this Kalima stuff it's like
getting like every so often they'll just
be like a squarish flake like a square
like a like a like a 3d square flake
yeah it's sensation oh my God it does
meld in for flakiness every day of the
week it's crazy I have to send you some
okay I'm into that I I usually use
melden all right have they sponsored you
yet what no do they do sponsorships no
but they should they should sponsor you
I tried to get air fryers to sponsor me
I was like do you understand and they
were like you're doing free marketing
anyway we don't need to pay you no
exactly yeah we're the idiots talking
about these companies without even being
paid by them where the fools yeah I know
it's so true okay Luke for people online
who don't follow you where should they
go I'm on Instagram and Tick Tock my
handle is at the Luke cook and uh I have
a podcast called The zadi Zone it's
wherever you get your podcasts why did
you choose the name the zaddy Zone well
because people named me zaddy after I
was um I played Lucifer in the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina and I played I was
Sabrina's dad and
um people started calling me Daddy and
then zaddy was the new pop term and
people started calling me zaddy and I
just really liked it I thought it was
funny and uh you know I wanted to make
sure that people didn't think it was a
just another podcast it was like gonna
be fun so I called it the zaddy Zone I I
I may change it it's been a lot of
explaining to people who are like just
look at me with these eyes and like what
it's like okay just it's called the
daddy Zone that's all I'm saying bye-bye
oh that's funny no don't change it I
like it it's got a good ring too okay
okay Luke thank you very much for coming
on it was nice meeting you finally
you're supposed to be a joy